twas the night before Black Friday when
all through the mall the biters alert
stiffly 10,000 and all the windows all
shattered the shoppers had fled it looks
like Black Friday brought black days
instead then down near the food court
arose such a clatter I sprang for my
post to see what was the matter then
what to my wondering eyes should appear
a fresh sheet transforming horn the
weird
but nowhere to go no safety in sight I
picked up my back prepared for a fight
rapids and bullets they came in the game
I call them by name you bastard you ass
you son of a [ __ ] you all look so
hungry
Peter stack on this outside the evils
howl Dan the horde came alive it would
take a Christmas miracle for old Frank
to survive
and then there they were right there on
the floor the exosuit and weapons I'd
asked Santa for in the spirit of giving
I let fire fly
I asked who won barbecue no reply the
strength of 10 men
I brought serious pain come meet your
mate Frank Quest is my name so I jumped
in my sleigh and went through the horn
spewing our bodies and guts and more
gold
it's so nice to be naughty I thought
with a grin I'm just getting started
let the sleigh ride begin Xbox 1s
starting at $2.99